au cours des dernières années les outils
technologiques ont beaucoup progressé en
foresterie
plusieurs parlent même d'une véritable
révolution et cet essor permet de
pratiquer une gestion des forêts plus
durable
dans le val saint françois près de
windsor en esprit une équipe s'apprête à
faire le suivi d'une plantation de
peupliers hybrides sur les terres de la
compagnie domtar est aujourd'hui
j'entends faire planification ou veulent
un secteur justicier wasquehal cours
d'eau deux chercheurs du centre
d'enseignement et de recherche en
foresterie le cerveau accompagne le
superviseur aux opérations forestières
de domtar ils vont mesurer la croissance
de la plantation établi il y a trois ans
c'est du haut des airs à l'aide d'un
drone qu'ils vont recueillir les données
l'attention du monde
décollage c'est parti pendant plusieurs
minutes le véhicule aérien survole la
plantation et capte des images à très
haute résolution des capteurs
infrarouges installé sur la caméra du
bronze fournissent des informations qui
seraient autrement invisible comme le
taux d'humidité et la vigueur de la
végétation des données révélatrices de
l'état de santé de la plantation
pendant que les manoeuvres aériennes se
poursuivent
mathieu varin et félix brochu marié
s'éloigne avec une bande gps pour la
pression ils prennent un point de
contrôle au sol et font des mesures de
hauteur et de densité des arbres le
chercheur mathieu varin france 8
correspondre ces mesures avec
l'information obtenue grâce aux drones
il va en extraire un modèle 3d
permettant d'estimer la hauteur de
chacun des arbres de la plantation
ces données serviront à la planification
des opérations forestières
ça nous permet par exemple de pouvoir
savoir à quelle vitesse elle pose c'est
quoi ce délire de succès et
éventuellement c'est le genre
d'informations qu'on aimerait qui
pourrait nous informer sur l'année
précise de récolte lorsque l'importation
roczen peu plus
les industriels ont recours aux drones
pour un territoire restreint mais aussi
aux images satellitaires et aux données
lidar qui couvre une étendue beaucoup
plus vaste le lidar light detection and
ranging est une technologie de
télédétection par laser un émetteur
installé sur un avion envoie des
centaines de milliers de faisceaux
lasers par seconde vers une cible au sol
cette lumière est réfléchie sur la
surface de la cible puis renvoyé à sa
source
le délai que met la lumière à retourner
au capteur permet de reconstituer les
données à colliger la force du leader
c'est de faire une pénétration de la
surface forestière par exemple dans ce
que si donc nous permet d'obtenir la
hauteur des arts mais aussi la le micro
relief
le coût de ces données est très élevé
depuis 2015 le ministère des forêts de
la faune et des parcs acquiert des
données lidar sur l'ensemble du sud du
québec et les rend accessibles aux
industriels mais pour faire le suivi de
la canopée elles deviennent désuète
après quelques années le cerveau utilise
donc des technologies complémentaires
avec les nouveaux capteurs
microsatellites mis en opération par la
nasa l'agencé spatiale européenne ou les
compagnies privées
on a des images de plus en plus précises
qui sont captés à des centaines de
kilomètres de la surface de la terre
[Musique]
à gauche près de lachute mathieu varin
du cerveau et des employés de la
coopérative terres à bois prennent les
mesures ne pondent un cours d'eau chez
un propriétaire demoiselle à partir des
données lidar le cerveau a fait une
modélisation pour cartographier les
cours d'eau de cette forêt privée avec
les méthodes traditionnelles utilisées
par exemple en photo interprétation
on n'était pas en mesure de voir ce
cours d'eau là parce qu'il y avait un
couvert forestier qui le cachait
maintenant que la présence du cours
d'eau est établi les mesures de pente
permettront de mieux le protéger lors
des opérations forestières futur comme
les travaux de voirie ou la récolte sont
cédés au préalable la position du solo
mais on peut aller chercher un peu
d'années alors ils sont disponibles on
voit les valves et pompeux les rues bas
mais par la suite on peut faire des
prescriptions civica dans lesquels on va
pouvoir faire apparaître les bandes
riveraines qui sont à protéger un peu
plus loin dans le boisé mathieu varin et
sa collègue viennent confirmer la
présence de milieux humides la
modélisation à partir des données lidar
permet d'identifier facilement ces
milieux fragiles
[Musique]
longtemps les forestiers ont dû marcher
la forêt pour suivre son évolution
l'essor fulgurant des outils
technologiques permet de faire une bonne
partie de ce travail beaucoup plus
rapidement avec précision et ultime mans
d'adopter des pratiques plus
respectueuses de l'environnement
une révolution qui se passe en
foresterie
ça transforme et industrie dans un
certain sens c'est ça permet ça permet
de faire de faire plus ça permet de
peaufiner nos façons de faire de faire
des meilleurs traitements forestier
[Musique]